andrei tiene un tanque de vidrio primero
quiere poner algunas canicas en él todas
del mismo volumen después quiere llenar
el tanque de agua hasta que esté
completamente lleno esta es la fórmula
para el volumen del agua que andrei debe
usar w w
medido en litros como una función del
número de canicas que use en w de nm es
decir podemos ver que la cantidad de
agua que necesitamos poner es una
función del número de canicas y esto es
igual a 32 menos 0.05 en bastante
interesante dice complete las siguientes
proposiciones con los valores faltantes
apropiados el volumen del tanque de
vidrio es espacio en blanco litros el
volumen de cada canica es espacio en
blanco litros
así que una cosa que podemos hacer o que
podemos pensar acerca del volumen del
tanque de vidrio es usar esta función
para averiguar cuánta agua necesitamos
si no tenemos canicas en el tanque
porque esa cantidad de agua va a ser el
volumen del tanque entero recuerda que
vamos a llenar el tanque de acuerdo a
cuántas canicas puede alojar así que
queremos averiguar cuánto vale w01 de
cero esta es la cantidad de agua que
necesitamos si no tenemos canicas dentro
y esto sea el volumen del tanque entero
y bueno cuánto será esto
bueno pues w de cero cuando n vale cero
este término desaparece y me quedo solo
con el 32 cierto así que doble un
tercero que es el volumen del tanque
volumen
del tanque entero del tanque esto va a
ser exactamente igual que 32 litros esto
va a ser igual que 32 litros y por lo
tanto lo voy a poner aquí el volumen del
tanque de vidrio es de 32 32 litros y
después nos pregunta el volumen de cada
canica es de espacio blanco litros así
que pensemos qué es lo que pasa con la
definición de esta función bueno lo más
que podemos tener es 32 es lo más que
podemos tener porque es la mayor
cantidad de agua que podemos poner si no
ponemos canicas
es decir llenamos el tanque con 32
litros y después cada canica que metamos
en el tanque vamos a poner 0.05 litros
menos de agua 0.05 litros menos de agua
y lo puedes ver aquí menos
punto 0 5 veces n así que por cada
canica vas a tener que poner 0.05 menos
litros lo que quiere decir que cada
canica tiene un volumen de 0.05 litros
ese es un volumen así que vamos a
escribirlo aquí el volumen de cada
canica es de 0.05 litros y tú puedes
comprobarlo de la siguiente manera
porque si tienes una canica entonces
tendremos que poner 0.05 aquí y entonces
tendremos 0.05 litros menos que los 32
litros que teníamos en el tanque y
porque será ese el caso porque la canica
está tomando 0.05 litros esto es cuánto
espacio está tomando